good afternoon and welcome to this panel
on cyber warfare and how technology is
changing the battlefield and I'm joined
by an expert panel
um of of people first of all we've got
Sarah Armstrong Smith who is the chief
security advisor in Europe for Microsoft
which plays a key role in cyber security
we've also got Nigel Inkster he had a
long and distinguished career at
Britain's secret intelligence service
MI6
and last but definitely not least we
have Sally Walker who spent about 25
years in National Security ending up as
director of cyber at gchq and she led
the effort to create the national cyber
force which is a fundamental part now of
UK cyber security both offensively and
defensively we're also going to be
joined by a minister from Ukraine in a
few minutes but I thought to start off
with given that Ukraine the war in
Ukraine is so current in our minds and
cyber has played such a fundamental role
in that conflict and we're learning so
much all the time that I'd ask the three
of you starting with Sarah just what
part has cyber played in the war in
Ukraine yeah thank you Deborah what
we're seeing now is a real example of a
hybrid War so we're used to thinking
about war as a the physical kinetic war
that we get to see on the television so
we see the missiles when it's landsc and
air but the Cyber element is the
invisible element and that's kind of one
of the key areas where we talk about
hybrid War so when we have the kinetic
well we have cyber attacks exactly the
same time and this is a prime example
particularly when we talk about Ukraine
so there's the tanks were rolling in on
the 24th of February actually the first
strikes were the day before on the 23rd
of February Microsoft in particular
detected over 300 simultaneous cyber
attacks and this was really trying to
knock out as much as Ukraine's critical
infrastructure as quickly as possible so
this is in Communications it's media
it's digital infrastructure and it's
really the hybrid war is trying to stop
the war as quickly as possible so we've
seen a massive increase in cyber attacks
the other element of a hybrid war is the
infamous animation Warfare as well and
this is the psychological warfare if you
like in terms of how they manipulate the
general population so they're targeting
the Ukrainian population the Russian
population Western allies but also
allies of Russia and as a whole
disinformation campaign I'm sure we'll
touch into that as well as we get
further into the panel yeah it's really
important to understand isn't it that
Warfare isn't the conventional bombs and
bullets alone anymore exactly so Nigel
what's your thoughts about the war in
Ukraine and how cyber is playing a part
in it well I you know I think you know I
would say yes everything that you know
Sarah's just said I agree with but I
think the lesson I'm taking from this is
that ultimately cyber plays an ancillary
role a very important role and in
sometimes a vital role but it's probably
utility its utility is probably
um in the kind of Gray Zone area that
precedes actual armed conflict and as
Sarah said in the information Warfare
domain
targeting populations around the world
and uh
um trying to persuade them of the
validity of uh Russia's message and
while that may not be working terribly
well in our part of the world in what
they call the global South it is
actually working rather effectively so
there is that the other thing that we're
seeing now is actually Russia's decided
that rather than take out uh
infrastructure using cyber means it's
easier just to physically destroy it so
you know the the physical aspects of
connectivity are also critical
um in this space the other thing I would
say and we're seeing this now is you
know the criticality of good air defense
systems which are dependent upon
satellites artificial intelligence uh to
function effectively
um Sally I'm going to bring you bring
you in after we've spoken to our guest
from Ukraine because it'd be great to
actually get your analysis on what he
has to say we're going to be speaking
now to George dabinski
um if technology uh survives out there
he is thank you ever so much he is
Ukraine's Deputy digital transformation
minister right on the physical front
line and absolutely the virtual front
line Minister thank you ever so much for
joining us here at Big Ideas live can
you just give us a sense from your
perspective of how cyber is playing a
role in this war in your country how
fundamental a role is that
uh good afternoon Deborah thank you for
having me and you know I heard just a
very wise comments from my colleagues
and I share them and in general but I
would say I would add a few things
exactly cyber became one of the
dimensions of this hybrid Warfare
together with information Warfare so
kinetic cyber information constructs
this war and I would say that we have
ongoing the first online War because of
everyone is able to follow the words of
the social media platform and the more
broader context I would say that it's
not only cyber but I would say that we
are talking about some digital uh
digital security and digital residence
because of as my colleagues mentioned uh
uh we have cyber attacks very critical
component we experience more than 1
370 cyber attacks and you know cyber
incidents it's more than 65 thousands
but uh also we are talking about the
telecommunication infrastructure data
security and connectivity of our
citizens uh their connection with with
the government so some uh dimension of
digital Securities and dimensional
dimension of uh digital resilience so
together with cyber security and
Communications physical security of data
security of personal data and even
security of this digital connection
between the citizen and the government
is also construct this uh context of
this uh Warfare and actually you know we
are actively using uh cyber Technologies
in the current Warfare particularly uh
to counter Russian disinformation I
would say that you know this information
is just extension of the internal
propaganda and brainwashing to to the
external markets and uh they are trying
to convince if uh the population of the
world is nothing is going on and nobody
died but we're using for a particular AI
uh Technologies to identify Russian even
not soldiers who are criminals
and to show them to find the social
profiles and to to contact their
families and to ask them to to take the
course back to to Russia so we are using
this uh cyber uh also multi-dimensional
unfortunately you know we did not create
cyber forces uh
final let's say and we have we were more
focused on cyber security and cyber
defense but right now we we understand
that we have to to do more proactively
area maybe it also will be part of this
Warfare and cyber warfare
I feel you're creating your own sort of
offensive cyber force do you mean
you know we decided we have uh we had
decree to create cyber forces it was uh
the decision was made I believe last
November but we did not create them
finally they are on the construction
right now so since 2014 when we had this
world and this war started and since it
was 1040 15 when we experienced a very
severe attacks on our energy
infrastructure we were more focused on
cyber security and cyber protection not
on offensive no not on Cyber offensive
and so you know that there are our
understanding of this uh Comfort the
Cyber domination was shaped by the
concept of cyber defense but as we see
you cannot fight in cyber Dimension
without cyber forces
so we we wish to to work on that as well
okay well thank you ever so much
Minister for joining us here and sharing
your experiences right from the front
line virtually and physically of Ukraine
um Sally what do you what do you make of
what the minister just said there about
how cyber is uh you know this you have
to defend against it but of course he's
clearly saying you also have to be
offensive and I know you don't like
those terms but so can you just explain
to us yeah you know what your thoughts
are and also more broadly how you would
describe the Cyber threat
so I think The Minister's comments just
reinforced the backdrop to this
conversation which is our society is
digitally dependent uh in everything
that we do from the classroom to the
boardroom to the front line
and every
um decision that we make is derived from
information
whether that information is trusted or
not is critical to whether we're
competent and that's whether we're
competent as a whole society
so in the context of cyber warfare yes
cyber is technology and yes cyber is I.T
but I think it would be deeply dangerous
for the debate to stop there because
cyber is completely a human challenge
um a deeply human challenge
and therefore we need to be thinking
about how we build National competence
National resilience and making sure that
that competences across the whole of our
society the debate ultimately is about
who we trust what we trust and how we
trust it and I think that The Minister's
comments uh really brought that home
and then looking to the Future it's a
really difficult debate around the
skills that we need do we need forces uh
do we need each and every citizen in
this room and I'd argue we need
everybody
and just to say that if you do have
questions to ask our panel you can scan
them on the QR code or if you're
watching on television or online you can
submit your questions on Twitter still
using the hashtag hashtag Big Ideas
live22
um Sarah just looking at the impact of
the war in Ukraine in terms of the cyber
attacks increasing globally there is no
geographical limitation for cyber have
we seen an increase in the threat from
cyber attacks following Russia's
large-scale invasion of Ukraine yeah I
think it's really good to put it into
context about what we're seeing not just
with the war in Ukraine but globally as
you said across every single country and
I always give you some visibility in
terms of what Microsoft is seeing so
every single day we collect and process
over 43 trillion Telemetry signals now
you think about the digital
infrastructure but you actually need a
lot of physical infrastructure as well
and if I kind of scan the room and
everyone's using smart devices and smart
technology that's all technology that's
all signals that's kind of giving off
kind of how do you make sense of 43
trillion signals well we've talked
already today about machine learning and
data analytics and trying to make sense
of what's going on but we're also
actively tracking about 250 different
threat actors so we've talked already
about some of the nation states but
actually there's a huge increase when it
comes to organized crime and this has
been really an impact of the global
pandemic so you only think of crime
particularly Street crime you might
think of like drugs and a lot of those
type of things but a lot of that's
moving online because what they're
identifying is cyber crime pays
unfortunately and so you have the
opportunist you have the people you
don't really need a lot of I.T skills
you don't need a lot of money you can
buy credentials you can buy kits you can
buy all of these things off the dark web
really really easy to get set up so to
be a cyber criminal
um you know it doesn't actually take a
lot of effort and that's where we're
seeing the increase and anything and
everything can be monetized I think
that's a really important so we're
thinking about cyber crime there's a
kind of Illusion that people are after
financial data realities are after any
data any data can be bought and sold and
as we're talking about you know the sort
of people and Enterprises and Nations
and it's kind of to Sally's Point what
are we really here to protect we're
really here to protect people and we're
here to protect data and you know when
we're talking about it from a digital
perspective as time goes on and time
progresses everything and every
everything is going to be digitally
connected in one way or another so cyber
security plays a role in absolutely
everything that we're doing and and
that's you know from our perspective
here in the UK during relative peace
time so it's important to think about
the fact that we're all basically on the
front line anyone with an electronic
device can be targeted Nigel can you
just give your thoughts uh we're talking
about cyber technology more broadly and
the future how is Warfare in the future
going to look
well you know we're back to close a bit
you know the difference between the the
the the nature and the character of
warfare you know as close if it said you
know the nature of warfare is unchanging
but the character of warfare changes
continuously the other thing to say is
you know remind ourselves there's a
Warfare is a complex adaptive process
and victory normally goes to the side
that proves most adaptive so making uh
predictions I think is very difficult
but there are certain things I think we
can safely assume one as I just said I
think at the end of the day you know
cyber
um attacks I mean I I don't like the
term cyber warfare I'm not sure what it
means nor does anybody else
um you know is is probably going to be
Preparatory and ancillary to the main
event which is still going to be a clash
of arms the other thing to think about
is the whole challenge of autonomous
systems and the United Nations has got
very exercised about this and is looking
at the whole question of Killer Robots
well I think we're a long way from that
you know no serious military thinker or
Commander that I know about wants you
know to find himself in a situation
where artificial intelligence systems or
machines are dictating the battle
rhythms and if we look at what's
happened in Ukraine the role of the
human being I think is still fundamental
Ukrainian forces have defeated a much
larger and on the face of it better
prepared Force Through you know the
skill of individual commanders you know
non-commissioned officers on the ground
and I don't think we're ever going to be
able to eliminate that from a central
role in Conflict but we do have issues I
mean we've already got loitering
Munitions and drones
um that are capable can be programmed to
attack without first phoning home so
we've kind of crossed that barrier how
much further we go it's very difficult
to say and of course there's been a lot
of work hasn't there in terms of that
cyber element defending it which is why
perhaps we haven't seen such devastating
cyber implications
um Sally can you just talk about what a
Cyber attack is you've you have a lot of
thoughts about how it's not about this
so-called Pearl Harbor cyber event it's
far more Insidious it's about attacking
our minds what is a Cyber attack what is
cyber warfare
oh how long have we got uh about two and
a half minutes yeah
um
so what is a Cyber attack
um I've got a phone here we've all got
phones here it is under attack
because it's getting spam emails that
are trying to steal my credentials and
trying to steal my information and
I'm probably the one responsible for
that attack
which is why the language is so
unhelpful because I logged on to a
station Wi-Fi on my way here and I
didn't think about whether it was a
trusted Network and it asked me for my
inside leg measurement and my phone
number I within seconds I was getting
spam text messages about covid and about
energy support payments so the system
is out there and we play into it and
even if our device is secure our
behavior is not
so anything that introduces
vulnerability to the system today
informs the capabilities and the options
that our adversaries have tomorrow and
that is I think unusual about the nature
of the Cyber threat that we face and
requires us to perhaps think a little
differently and possibly change the
language and it's interesting that a lot
of the early cyber security language was
actually in terms of health infection
viruses and some of the lessons that
we've learned from covid are deeply
relevant to securing ourselves and
making ourselves safer in a cyber
conflict of the future Well Ricky thunac
our new prime minister is actually just
visiting Ukraine at the moment for the
first time he's been meeting with the
president and he's been saying about how
the UK is going to be providing more
weapons to help the ukrainians like what
is the biggest assistance that the UK
can give Ukraine to help deal with these
threats in the Cyber domain actually
Sally if I go to you first
brain power so this is a human endeavor
this is about the skills that we need
and it's about different thinking and if
you bring together brilliant people who
understand
telecommunications networks devices
Logistics supplies
weapons programs you can then work with
those individuals to make their systems
more safe because if you're an engineer
building something you don't tend to
think I wonder how this can be broken
but that's what our adversaries are
doing to us they're not looking for
normal use of our systems and our
capabilities and our infrastructure and
that information they're looking for
abnormal use and that requires a
different mindset and a different skill
set
and those skills are out there they're
out there in every Walk of Life so we
need to bring people into this fight
for your average person in the boardroom
perhaps isn't looking for a fight
they're looking for a purpose and I
think the ukrainians have done that
particularly well in uniting around a
noble cause and a trusted brand of their
flag and just one very quick thing
before I go to the audience questions I
just wanted to talk about Microsoft and
how industry as well in this evolving
field where actually industry often
knows more than government it's quite a
unique situation you've got Elon Musk
helping the ukrainians with his
um technology can you just talk very
briefly about the role that the
fundamental role that industry has to
play in in the Ukraine conflict I think
it's a really great example like we've
been talking about with the death
breadth and scale and putting that
intelligence to work and I think one of
the things that we've identified that's
really important and I would say as a
benefit of everything that's happened if
you can any good that's come out of this
is the public and private sector
collaboration so historically when we're
talking about nation-state threats we're
talking about this level of intelligence
that would have been shared with
government agencies intelligent agencies
across different governments very rarely
would that have been shared to the
general public and one of the things
that we found is really really important
is to share and educate the general
public as much as possible so what
you'll see from us is that we have
provided less early Lessons Learned and
getting out there sharing it so people
can make decisions
um about and be more educated as we
talked about the fact that you know we
are utilizing devices or utilizing data
you're doing all of these things and the
kind of the last point I would just sort
of make is you made the point that
earlier Deborah about their strategy is
different in peacetime versus wartime in
peace time a lot of our governments a
lot of our a lot of our need is to keep
our data as close to us as possible and
actually in wartime we need to get the
data as far away as possible and that's
been a really big lesson with about
empowerment your understanding of
where's my data who's got access to it
the level of control of that data is so
key and it's so important and so it's
two real lessons learned that we could
take away it's really quite simple is we
have to protect the access in and the X
out so stop them getting access into our
data into our environments and doing all
those things and stop them getting
access to the data it's the data that's
really that they're after so we can kind
of bridge the gap on those two areas
we're going to be on to a really good
thing thank you so now we're going to
some questions from the audience and
online is Sam here in the audience
please raise a hand maybe Sam don't be
shy up better cup at the back
there's an average that military's um
the last war and I'm wondering if
there's an equivalent of that within
cyber by which I mean an area of cyber
that it might be tempting for say the UK
military or government to focus on which
perhaps it shouldn't do in favor of
something else thank you he wants to
take that can you just repeat the the
essence of the question um yeah there's
an old adage that militaries always try
to fight the last war is there an
equivalent of that within cyber warfare
Nigel why don't you go for that well
very a very good question you know I
think actually the reality is that
militaries are still struggling to come
to terms with the integration of cyber
capabilities into their current
practices so um I don't think you know
there is a second war to be fought we're
still fighting the first one so to speak
um and this has been you know quite
difficult because you know in the nature
of things people you know want to stick
to what they know and it has been really
difficult I think to get a lot of
military Commanders you know to accept
you know the necessity of integrating
these capabilities into
um you know other other ones with which
um they are more familiar that's not a
criticism all because some have been
very Visionary and Forward Thinking in
the way that they've they've approached
this but integrating it you know has
been difficult so we're still you know
in the first phase here absolutely and
bring you can
empowering a soldier to send a tweet
seems to be beyond the ministry of
Defense quite often which links quite
nicely to the next question from Alison
in the audience at the front here please
hi thank you
um what role do you think social media
plays as and as you say an extra
auxiliary in war with Ukrainian soldiers
now posting tick tocks of themselves on
the battlefield
um in terms of maybe proliferating
information or putting potential
rallying power in the hands of the
ordinary citizen
um Sally do you want to go for that one
um yeah it's obviously a very powerful
tool um and we've talked about Ukraine
and and them having their noble cause
and their trusted brand to rally um
troops but they but that has equally
been used on the flip side by isil who
did the same thing with their black flag
and their recruitment of people to their
cause you know reaching around the world
into the bedrooms of those who perhaps
um accepted their Twisted ideology and
you know that that is a different War we
fought at a different time but actually
the lessons are similar
um as we look into Ukraine and look to
the Future and did you have any any
thoughts on that on social media yeah it
kind of comes back to what I said at the
beginning about information Warfare and
disinformation now social media is a
great tool to be able to amplify to see
what's going on to get those messages
out there it can also be used for
nefarious purposes so one of the again
one of the key Lessons Learned From This
hybrid war is that disinformation it's
the false news it's the fake news and
how that's being proliferated across
social media and its design is to elicit
a response with regards to you know if
you're trying to get people to fear
what's going on or you're trying to
build a particular narrative about you
know the different areas depending on
where you'll come from and so it's very
highly targeted and this is actually a
big area of focus for Microsoft as well
going forward in terms of how we can
educate how do we educate people to
understand the original source of the
picture so a lot of pictures can be
doctored a lot of pictures that you're
seeing right now are not even from the
Ukraine war they could be from a war X
number of years ago it could be
something that someone's created and so
when you're watching this and you're
sharing this you need to make sure that
again that from an education perspective
that what Can Microsoft do and other big
tech companies to help you understand
the original Source the true Source
where you can go to get educated find
out real information and like Sky News
for example
um but also just potentially where that
image may have been doctored and where
that image may have been reused
elsewhere so it's important it's a
really great question about how social
media is a really powerful tool but can
also be used as real negative tool as
well well thank you very much to the
panelists for this fascinating
discussion we could go on all afternoon
but there's a lot more here at Big Ideas
now I